الحكم على سعد المجرد رحيل شادي زيدان
عوده الجونه والاحتفالات تعوم السعوديه في
ذكرى يوم التاسيس اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
قضت محكمه فرنسيه بالسجن سته اعوام على
المغني المغربي سعد المجرد بتهمه الاغتصاب
والاعتداء على شابه فرنسيه في غرفه فندق
بباريس عام 2016 وفقا لقناه بي ام اف تي
في الفرنسيه المتعاونه مع شبكه سي ان ان
وذكرت القناه انه بعد سبع سنوات من
المداولات قالت المحكمه انها مقتنعه بحدوث
الاغتصاب الذي تم وصفه بشكل ثابت ودقيق من
قبل المدعي المدنيه وعبر والد المجرد بشير
عبده في تدوينه عبر حسابه على انستجرام عن
حزن ودخول عائلته لما اقدم عليه القضاء
الفرنسي بحق ولده الذي لا يستحق هذا
القرار القاسي الغامض بحسب تعبيره وطلب
محبيهم بالدعاء لهم بالصبر والتحمل ريثما
ياتي الفرج
وفي خبر صادم اخر فجع الوسط الفني السوري
الاسبوع الماضي بوفاه الفنان السوري شادي
زيدان عن عمري 49 عاما بعد تعرضه لازمه
قلبيه ودماغيه مفاجئه دخل على اثرها في
غيبوبه قرابه الاسبوع الى ان فارق الحياه
السبت الماضي ونعاه شقيقها الفنان ايمن
ووائل زيدان بكلمات مؤثره
وكان اخر ما نشره الراحل عبر حساباته
الرسميه على مواقع التواصل مشاركته مع
عائلته وعدد من المتطوعين في عمليه جمع
المساعدات لمتضرري الزلزال في سوريا
[موسيقى]
وبعيدا عن الاخبار الحزينه والصادمه
الاسبوع الماضي تفاعل محبو الفنانه
اللبنانيه الشابه مليكه عاصي الحلاني مع
خبر خطوبتها من كميل ابي خليل الذي اعلنته
من خلال فيديو ومجموعه صور رومانسيه
لخطيبها وهو يقدم لها عرض الزواج في باريس
نشرتها عبر حسابها الرسمي على انستجرام
وظهرت مؤخرا الصور الرسميه لحفل الخطوبه
مع العائله
وفي خبر سعيد لعشاق السينما اعلن مهرجان
جونا السينمائي في مصر عن موعد اقامه
دورته السادسه في اكتوبر المقبل بالتزامن
مع اعلان تعيين عمرو منسي المشارك المؤسس
في المهرجان مديرا تنفيذيا له وكان مهرجان
الجونه قد توقف بشكل مفاجئ العام الماضي
بعد سلسله من الازمات شهدتها دورته
الخامسه في 2021
واخيرا عمت الاحتفالات السعوديه في ذكرى
يوم التاسيس وحققت تفاعلا كبيرا على منصات
التواصل في المملكه ولفت النجم نادي النصر
كريستيانو رونالدو الانظار بالثوب وزيد
تقليدي السعودي وادائه رقصه العارضه الى
جانب نجوم النادي احتفاء بهذه المناسبه
وشهدت رياض الاسبوع الماضي ايضا عوده
النجم المصري احمد حلمي الى خشبه المسرح
بعد سنوات طويله في عروض مسرحيه ميمو كما
حقق اداء ليشاكيز على ايقاع فرقه تراثيه
سعوديه في العلا تفاعلا كبيرا على منصات
التواصل
[موسيقى]